team Trump going on offense in the
Ukraine whistleblower controversy the
president hammering Joe Biden and is
accusing him of lying while the former
VP is firing back
what Biden did is a disgrace what his
son did is a disgrace the son took money
from Ukraine the son took money from
China a lot of money from China China
would love to see he would they can
think of nothing did rather see then
Biden get in
what Biden did was wrong you should be
looking at Trump Trump's doing this
because knows I'll beat him like a drum
and he's using the abuse of power and
every element of the presidency to try
to do something to smear me okay
Democrats predictably seizing on the
story even though they don't have all
the facts for example a source is
telling Fox News the whistleblower
doesn't even have quote first-hand
knowledge of what Trump said to the
president of Ukraine that of course is
not stopping calls for Trump's
impeachment it is time for us to call
out this illegal behavior and start
impeachment proceedings right now so of
course it's in an impeachable offense
there is no way to defend the lack of
progress on impeachment especially after
what we have just learned
we need to absolutely right away begin
impeachment proceedings he's got to go
but if the president is essentially
withholding military aid at the same
time that he is trying to browbeat a
foreign leader into doing something you
elicit that is providing dirt on his
opponent during a presidential campaign
then that may be the only remedy and
while the majority of the media is
focusing on Trump's role in this this
New Yorker article getting new attention
it points the finger at the Democratic
frontrunner asking quote will hunter
Biden jeopardize his father's campaign
and in that article one they report that
you know although that Joe Biden said oh
I never talked about any sort of
international business dealings with my
son hunter says oh yeah we talked about
it yeah so doesn't look too good does it
I think it doesn't look so good for
Trump why well I mean that everybody is
investigated this is not new about
hunter Biden and his dad I mean Trump
calling the son
druggy I didn't like that at all but
just forget that for a second you
brought it up but the whole thing the
whole thing is just you know Trump has a
style which is he goes on the offensive
when he is under attack and I think
that's what we see and I think Joe
Biden's right Joe Biden sees that he is
the target of trumps are because Trump
sees and every poll indicates Biden
could beat him like a drum but to me the
thing is and I hope everybody at this
table can agree on this the White House
should release the transcript because
that's what the law requires that's not
it's not a known as argument yes it is
it says that if the IG the Inspector
General for the Director of National
Intelligence deems this an urgent
concern it should go to the car you know
what it wasn't deemed an urgent surprise
no it wasn't justice the more code 53:3
K just say that it didn't rise the level
why don't we declassify everything can't
have any conversation with a foreign
leader
he'll just release the transcript to the
public and you know what while we're at
it let's do classify the FISA reports
because nothing was right one you know
what rock obama tried to use us money to
extort a foreign power into providing
information on the torture body just did
no he's roll the tape yeah roll that
wasn't ecology that was an extortion why
not give me give me a million dollars
sorry you're not the president the
president said I said call
I think it was six hours I looked I said
we leave in six hours if the prosecutor
is not fired you're not getting the
money yes he said fire the prosecutor
investigating he also said that he never
spoke to his son about this which you
know isn't true but president has a
right to talk about any problem who
defines this is wrong he's just pursuing
a question but you know the media should
be happy that he's trying to investigate
a possible infraction they should be
they should be applauding but you know
this is reaching pure parity when CNN
trots out Carl Bernstein to say for the
400th time this is worse than Watergate
you know it's falling apart imagine
living with Carl Bernstein E the food
arrives late at the restaurant this is
worse than Watergate his iPhone charger
isn't working this is worse than
Watergate no dairy creamer this is worse
than water again does he get royalties
every time he says that but that's just
one of them that's just one of the signs
that this is all falling apart
the media's hair catches on fire too
early and we all get so jaded we don't
trust them anymore
I don't believe anything anymore you
know what was that conversation between
I think was Madea and Barack Obama that
was caught on the hot mic when he said
you know just give me a little more
flexibility until after the election
against Romney and he says yes I'll
transmit that to Vladimir issue was the
other thing and that happens is that
this basically thrust to the issue
I'm sorry thrust to the forefront two
basic issues that the Democrats have
been trying to stave off the first one
is Pelosi has been try to hold off her
caucus to and say we don't need it she's
like I'm not for impeachment she sends a
letter than yesterday because I do think
they jumped the gun right there if you
could say like is it just a good idea to
be pressuring like I don't know okay
fine president says he wants to release
the transcript he says he wants to
release the physis documents too so he
has the power to do that and I'm not for
releasing these types of transcripts I
think that the president should be able
to have that but if it's going to go to
this extent release it and then
everybody can have the debate about it
the other one that the Democrats have
been trying to
stave off is the question about hunter
Biden's business dealings that New
Yorker article ran last spring nobody
really paid that much attention hadn't
announced yet yeah it's classic
deflection strategy this is what always
happens anytime anyone on the left does
something bad we get a leak as to how
and why the president did something
worse because the Democrats don't want
to talk about hunter Biden being on the
board of the Ukranian company are
getting bankrolled by China or having
his dad talked about you know demanding
that the prosecutor be fired all of
those are hideous subjects for the left
and you're right they've been around for
quite some time that's why it's so
frustrating for the GOP I will say the
only silver lining to this however is
the now re kind of regrown clamor by
some of them including AOC to start
those impeachment proceedings because
it's calling attention to the civil war
what debits you know what this could be
all a democratic strategy to get Biden
out well we are hearing that Hillary
actually was behind the initial hunter
Biden leak when she was trying to scare
Joe off 2016 but you didn't know that
one